[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar pro-calcitone and aided
antibiotic stewardship for lower
respiratory tract infections
i am marie stone of lab roots and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by thermo fisher scientific
to learn more visit procalcitonin.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
i'd like to now welcome our speaker
dr edward j septimus clinical professor
at texas a m college of medicine
senior lecturer department of population
medicine harvard medical school
and professor and distinguished senior
fellow school of public health george
mason university
dr septimus you may now begin your
presentation
well thanks very much and welcome
everyone i hope that this will be
meaningful and valuable after the
presentation so we're going to get
started and here's my agenda
there'll be a brief introduction
i'm going to spend some time talking
about the evolving etiologies of
community acquired pneumonia which i'll
be calling cap
we'll look at whether or not there's any
uh value of using bio markers
in the management for adults with cap
and then i'm going to shift gears to
those folks who present with
exacerbation of copd
who have suspected
lower respiratory tract infections and
then some final thoughts and conclusions
so let's start off with the evolving
etiology for cap back in the
pre-antibiotic era the king of
organisms was clearly the pneumococcus
which we now call streptococcus
pneumoniae and you can see that was
almost 95 plus percent
of organisms that were identified
as we move into the 1930s and 40s we
began to recognize the concept of
so-called atypical
pneumonia uh the eaton lambert which now
became mycoplasma was discovered as a
possible cause of pneumonia especially
in pediatrics
and then during world war ii
we began to see other causes of
pneumonia identified the biggies being
pneumococcus influenza the atypicals and
now virus
especially adenovirus and other viruses
as they lived in these barracks with
poor ventilation
uh and then as we get towards the end of
the 1965-1967
time period
we began to look at pneumococcal
pneumonia still being the predominant
organism but as we look at the hopkins
study in 1971 to 1972 with a very
aggressive approach
to making an ideological
pathogen diagnosis for cap
they used either nasal tracheal tube or
something that i did in my early days in
the 1970s transtracheal aspirates where
you actually went through the
crycopharyngeal
membrane and actually put a catheter
down into the trachea to obtain a uh
a specimen that was free of oral
pharyngeal contamination got you really
nice specimen but you can imagine
it was somewhat invasive uh the
bacterial causes that were identified
88 of the cases had a bacteria
was once again the pneumococcus being
about 30 but we began to see some other
organisms appear
one of them being hemophilus
now as we move into the 1980s we began
to see some new organisms that were
identified we mentioned tomophilus
becoming more and more important we
always thought of a motherless only
being in pediatrics a number of these
were non-type-able
chlamydia
suicide was was identified and then in
the landmark study uh looking at
pneumonia in philadelphia and then
subsequently in other places including
pittsburgh
legionella was identified as a potential
cause of community acquired pneumonia
moving into this
century in the first decade
there were three very nice studies which
i'm highlighting because for the first
time
we began to get tests
that were capable of looking at viruses
using pcrs so two of these studies did
that once again you can see pneumococcus
or strep pneumoniae being the most
common
but you can see viruses were mentioned
in about 20 to 30 percent of two of
these studies were viruses were looked
at and this was sort of new especially
for those of us who do primarily adult
medicine
because we had always associated viral
pneumonia with pediatrics
occasionally influenza pneumonia but to
see 20 to 30 percent for adults
that was new
uh in terms of the atypical as you can
see that
one of the studies in the uk
of decent plurality had some atypicals
but the other two studies not many
and you can see the pneumococcus once
again as i'm clicking on
still the number one bacterial pathogen
but
as other studies have shown and why so
many treatment guidelines uh use empiric
therapy about 44
uh in most studies sometimes over 50
percent
no pathogen is identified
so if we look now looking at the jane
study that was published in 2015
looking at community acquired pneumonias
in hospitalized adults we see that again
viral pathogens
are mentioned here in a nice plurality
uh and so that we're beginning to see
multiple studies in adults
confirming that anywhere from 15 to 30
of patients where you look for viruses
viruses may be
either by themselves or co-infected with
bacteria or causing cap
and then as we move into the more recent
studies there's three that i've
highlighted here and again you see the
same pattern you can see viruses here
20 and 27 this last study did not look
at pcrs
for viruses again of the bacteria you
begin to see that there's not quite as
many pneumococci here
that you saw before
again staph aureus hemophilus in one of
these studies but again the big message
here that we can't forget about the
viruses and as we mentioned before
unless you really are very aggressive in
search
50 plus percent of cap patients
do not have a pathogen identified and
that creates we'll talk a little while
problems around stewardship
now if you look at this nice article
that was published recently
and just looked at the severe partial
these are patients that meet the
criteria that adsa
uh mentions that looks at this but i
think as you can see with severe disease
as you can see here
you can see it's staph aureus and
pneumococcus which you can see the
percentages are somewhat lower than what
you've been accustomed to and then if
you look at the bottom a pathogen
identified in only 34 of patients with
severe cap however
there were no viral pcrs performed in
this study and only 10 of blood cultures
were positive
even with severe cap
and then i want to highlight another
study that was actually done in houston
very careful study done
good sputum samples they screened
speedums to make sure that it was a good
quality specimen they did quantitation
and as shown here the threshold for
typical bacterial infections was greater
than 10 to the fifth and for those that
were quote normal respiratory flora they
looked at a threshold of greater than 10
to the sixth so they were very
aggressive at trying to identify a
pathogen they did have viral studies
available so if they looked at the study
all but about five percent
who are not able to determine an
etiology when they considered normal
respiratory flora and if we consider it
the pathogenesis for pneumonia generally
is aspiration
and so they were asking the question
could large numbers of
respiratory bacteria
be a cause of pneumonia and be part of
the reason we don't identify
pathogens so what they did they had
recognized bacterial pathogens that
would be the pneumococcus and hemophilus
the ones that you think of in about 45
percent of cases
co-infection with typical bacteria that
is with viral
another oh 11 to 12
respiratory viruses alone around 13.3
percent here's that normal flora nothing
else grew high numbers of bacteria
greater than 10 to the sixth
about 17 to 8 percent and then if they
added normal respiratory flora plus a
co-infection with the virus another 8.3
percent so if you add up
the respiratory virus alone co-infection
with respiratory virus you can see
that respiratory viruses are an
important component of cap now that we
can actually measure this with molecular
studies but they got the undetermined
down
to around five percent doing very very
careful studies you making sure they had
a good quality specimen
the other thing that's impacting i think
the
bacterial ideology is pneumococcal
vaccine as you know we now just have a
new pneumococcal vaccine that just came
out
and just like in in pediatrics as well
as adults
in the united states especially with
smoking cessation programs this is what
we're seeing
in the u.s we're seeing a very nice
reduction that top graph
with those circles
look at
the reduction of pneumococcal disease
starting from the beginning of the last
century
up till now
at least through 2015.
that's in contrast to europe which is
the red circles that you see there
and you can see they haven't had the
same reduction that we had in this
country and the two factors identified
number one
is their pneumococcal vaccination rate
and number two that they have a higher
incidence of smoking so you can see the
impact of vaccination
on on streptococcus pneumoniae probably
is also leading to a decline in its
incidence
now with that there are some newer
diagnostic panels which have come online
in the last three to four years and
these are the so-called multiplex
pneumonia panels now we're not talking
about the upper respiratory panels no
not the lower respiratory panels and
there's two that are available
the one on the left is so-called film
array
it contains viruses
the typical bacteria you see in the
middle done by a semi-quantitative
measure
they have the atypicals that are also
qualitative and then they have the
typical resistance genes that you're
familiar with the curators on the right
have much the same bacteria and they
have an addition here stenotrophomonas
which is not in the biofire but they
don't have any viruses they have many of
the same resistance genes plus oxide 23
and 24
and they add pneumocystis geravichi or
the old pneumocystis cariniii pneumonia
which in some populations uh can be an
important pathogen which has now been
reclassified as a fungus so the panels
have a lot of overlap but one has
viruses one has a pneumocystis they both
have resistance genes
so
again this is beginning to slowly get
into routine
microbiology labs but this is the last
of the big syndromic panels to be
introduced
so with that as a background knowing
it's difficult to define the etiology of
cap
in
giving you the idea that viruses may be
important some by itself some with
co-infections
what additional tools do we have because
these multiplex lower respiratory panels
are are not readily available so what do
we have that's available now and is
there a role for biomarkers so let me
give you some in inconvenient truth
which is why i think we need to use all
of the tools we have
cap whether it's the ats idsa guidelines
the the guidelines that i just looked at
from australia they all rely on empiric
antimicrobial therapy that means before
we identify a pathogen as you can see
unless you really really try hard
half the time we don't identify an
actual pathogen let alone a bacteria
so we rely on empiric therapies based on
what the most likely bacterial pathogens
may be
however
large studies that use extensive
microbiological testing which i've just
gone through
show you that viruses may be more
important than we thought with cap and
as you know most antibacterial
antibiotics
don't work for viruses and may have a
negative impact on the host microbiome
and the development of resistance side
effects
and c diff
other respiratory infections including
tracheal bronchitis upper respiratory
copd with exacerbations
the burden of bacterial infection in
that population generally tends to be
low yet
many of these patients get antibacterial
agents
we know that better diagnostics are
needed to rapidly and accurately
identify patients who might benefit from
antibacterial therapy not antiviral but
antibacterial and many of these things
are beginning to come online with this
explosion of new rapid diagnostic
platforms into including the lower
respiratory panels that i just went over
but despite all these
advances
until we can get reliable
panels that can identify low respiratory
pathogens
we still have about 40 percent even in
high quality studies
where a pathogen is not identified so
what are the tools we have available now
also the host response such as
temperature
y camp
c-reactive proteins etc
are very uh the sensitivity and
specificity is is not all that great
and it doesn't always accurately
distinguish between bacteria and virals
there is a biomarker procalcitonin which
may provide additional information
in the sense that procalcitonin levels
tend to be up in bacterial infection and
normal in most viral infections so
that's a biomarker we have available to
now and in fact there are several
studies that have demonstrated looking
at procalcitonin
for respiratory infections which can
greatly reduce
antibacterial exposure
without increasing the rate of disease
progression treatment failures and can
reduce antibacterial exposures and again
the challenge has been what are the
thresholds that can reliably be
distinguished between bacterial
and viral etiologies
so with that here's sort of a summary of
some of the things that we have
available to us now
uh with the exception of pro-calcitonin
which i'll consider separately one we
mentioned about fever
certainly is a sensitive for
inflammation but it doesn't distinguish
between viral and bacterial a white
count again
many bacterial infections have high
white counts but we can see stress
reactions to viruses and we can see
suppression of white count
with severe bacterial infections
cytokines are great in terms of the
laboratory they rapidly get induced but
these are mainly laboratory tools for
research
crps are readily available there is some
specificity uh for infection and
inflammation
it's inexpensive relatively easy to get
done
but it's not as specific for bacterial
infection as the biomarker procalcitonin
which is at the bottom of the slide
and it's
procalcitonin can be very helpful uh in
the first six to twelve hours
i'll show you the kinetics later
uh
it is induced
and produced in response uh to bacteria
and it's relatively
it's relatively good
in most cases of separating virus from
bacteria we'll show you some of the some
of the exceptions
so here's the dynamics
so in patients who have bacterial
infections on the left
through activation of il6 and tnf alpha
procalcitonin is is produced in multiple
organs and it goes up
for most viral infections where we have
interferon gamma produced in fact
procalcitonin tends to be suppressed
and so if you look at the kinetics of
procalcitonin
you can see again this is a a product
that has to be made by a variety of
organs
so when a bacteria is found we get
induction of some of those inflammatory
cytokines
you can see that within three to six
hours usually that's what it takes to
rise for bacterial infections
we see
the ability to detect procalcitonin
meaning if you were to get someone in
the first hour or two and you draw a pro
calcitonin level it could be falsely low
or undetected and in that situation
repeating it three to six hours is a
recommendation we'll come back and talk
about that
it peaks at about 18 to 24 hours and
then if effective therapy is started and
this is important
we see the kinetics the half-life of
procalciton is about 24 hours so it
takes about 24 hours of appropriate
therapy before we begin to see a
reduction
and with each day
we can see about a 50
reduction
if it remains elevated is a couple of
explanations one is you have the wrong
drug as the treatment is not effective
the second may be you may not have good
source control so it can be looked at
based on the kinetics of whether or not
the patient's responding appropriately
to the therapy that's being administered
now this is a very nice algorithm uh
that was published
in lancet a little about a decade ago
about how do you interpret procalcitonin
because that's an important
consideration so here's the top
is guidelines for starting antibiotics
the second group are guidelines for
continuing or stopping of antibiotics so
procalcitonin can be used on the front
end to decide whether or not you want to
start an antibiotic at all and on the
back end looking at duration of therapy
based on the kinetic clearance
which are i reviewed
on this particular slide here based on
the half-life of the drug with effective
therapy
so if you look at this if the patient's
concentration is generally less than
0.25
antibiotics are strongly discouraged as
i mentioned sometimes you may want to
get a second
uh pro-calcitonin level if you think you
get someone very early because it takes
three to six hours for pro-calcitonin
level to come up
and so a second level may be appropriate
depending upon where in the course of
infection you see the patient
concentration between 0.25 and 0.5
is in the sort of a gray area but most
people say and you have to correlate the
procalcitonin with your patient
and so if if you still
think bacterial infection is unlikely
and the level is less than 0.5
antibiotics are discouraged when it's
greater than 0.5
generally speaking that's when we begin
to get more concern that we probably
should start antibiotics and certainly
if it's greater than one
the bottom part says you've already
started antibiotics
uh what's some guidance
when we can stop it well one thing is if
it's less than 0.25 regardless
strongly encourage people to stop
antibiotics
now here's the thing if it's decreased
by at least 80 percent from the peak
concentration
or it's gone down to between 0.5 and
excuse me 0.25 and 0.5 we strongly
encourage antibiotics to be stopped so
in general the more severe the bacterial
infection the higher the level we talked
about the clearance of the of
procalcitonin and so it may take a while
if you start off with a 10 or 20 mic
level
to get down to that 0.25 or 0.5 so you
can use the 80 clearance
as a measure to stop antibiotics so
that's the two things that people use in
terms of looking at duration of therapy
uh you know if it's decreased by by
greater than
80 percent but still greater than 0.5
most people would say i'm going to
continue antibiotics until it gets lower
and obviously if it doesn't come down
you either have the wrong diagnosis or
you have a source control problem
and so you need to look further so this
is pretty good guidance again i'm going
to emphasize this over and over again
always correlating
this test and any other tests you get
at the bedside integrating that into
other clinical and laboratory measures
in making decisions
now there are some false negatives i've
already discussed early in the course of
infection
you may want to get a second one if you
have a very localized infection a
bacterial
group based rep
maxillary sinusoidal cystitis skin
abscesses osteomyelitis
subacute endocarditis
they all tend to have normal
pro-calcitonin levels despite the fact
you see
let's say you see a boil
that's obviously a bacterial infection
most time due to staph you're unlikely
to see pro-calcitonin levels go up in
that situation unless you have systemic
dissemination
and mycoplasma which is one of the
atypicals tends to have levels that are
slightly higher than viral but lower
than bacterial so there's a kind where
you may see some some false negatives
now where can you see
non-bacterial causes of elevated
procalcitonin which i've defined as
being
false positive any severe physiological
stress
initial post-op
burns
bowel ischemia pancreatitis
strokes
shock of any kind
some of the highest pro calcium tonal
levels i've seen actually have occurred
with cardiogenic shock where you get the
full-blown cytokine
activation for all the world that looks
like septic shock but in fact it's due
to cardiogenic shock can greatly elevate
procalcitonin when you see that and the
cause is cardiac it's because of that
inflammatory response there are certain
malignancies
certain medications there are
non-bacterial pathogens malaria will
elevate procalcitonin candida infections
by the way will elevate procalcitonin
and then a word of caution
about patients who have renal
insufficiency whether acute or chronic
procalcitonin generally is cleared
renally and so the value of
pro-calcitonin in renal insufficiency
is very difficult to interpret and we
generally tend to discourage people
from measuring it if they have renal
insufficiency now
what about for cap
here's a very nice study that was
published a couple years back
as you can see on the left this is viral
these are the atypicals remember i told
you the atypicals tend to be a little
bit higher than viral and here's the
typical bacterial and you can see a very
marked difference
between the viral
and the bacteria but you can see there's
some overlap
and this has been one of the things that
have caused people some heartburn about
is there an appropriate cutoff
that clearly can distinguish
bacterial from viral you can see if you
get into a viral infection when you get
the inflammatory process and we'll talk
about about covid
this can sometimes occur so that's why i
always say you've got to look at the
patient generally with mycobacterium you
don't see much of an elevation but you
can see
the higher the value
the more likely it is discriminating
between
viral and bacterial but you've got to
look at your patient and take all those
factors into account
now if you look at procalcitonin guided
for standard respiratory tract
infections and you look at
cap and you look at the number of
patients who are actually on antibiotics
you can see
that patients who get pro calcitonin
guided therapy
have much less exposure
okay this is a randomized trial
administering antibiotic based on a
pro-calcitonin algorithm with predefined
cutoffs for initiating and stopping
antibiotics okay
and the other group control group just
use standard guidelines
as you can see the procalcitonin
guidance compared to standard therapy
okay now i will tell you there was
similar rates of adverse reactions
however there was much lower
rates of antibiotic exposure and lower
rates of antibiotic associated adverse
events so get integrating procalcitonin
you decrease the duration of antibiotics
the amount of antibiotic days and you
decrease side effects due to the
antibiotics and you can do that safely
as well
so i always want to kind of bring this
back to the bedside because that's how
do you apply what we've just talked
about to a patient
so this is a a typical 61 year old
patient who came in
who had underlying hypertension was on
medication
had a 10-day dry cough generalized body
aches for four days this was in 2020
during the one of our big surges for
covid i'll tell you that in advance
patient was febrile his white cat was
normal but he had a lymphopenia
mild elevation of his liver function
test his procalcitonin level was
undetected but look at the crp crp was 1
124.
most other viral infections we don't
usually see crps elevated but with covid
there's this background inflammatory
response
we see low procalcitonin in high
crps and we've learned that over the
years chest x-rays showed a typical
ground glass appearance and you can see
the vital signs that are there uh his
unfortunately the patient got worse uh
got more progressive infiltrates and
i'll show you the initial chest x-ray
which is here which sees this bilateral
interstitial type pneumonia very
non-specific
but fairly consistent with a viral
process
now what happened to the patient
blood cultures were drawn he was started
on the typical cap guideline
things of the zithromycin and
ceftriaxone for severe cap
his pcr came back on day two that
indicated that he had coving pneumonia
he unfortunately had to be intubated
placed on mechanical ventilation
because the covet test was positive and
the data was emerging of the
benefit of dexamethasone dexamethasone
was added at that time
they did do cultures through the
tracheal aspirate now that the patient's
intubated so he had a good quality
specimen from the lower respiratory
tract and a couple of things to keep in
mind one only few white cells were seen
and the majority of people have
clear bacterial infections they have
what we call
purulent which means there's greater
than 25 white cells per per low power
field
this only had few and the gram stain was
non-specific and so a couple of gram
positive cocci
the blood cultures remained negative and
the tracheal aspirate was eventually
read out as being quote normal flora and
i've already discussed the value of what
that means or doesn't mean in this case
with very few white cells
and i can tell you the colony count
being very low
it's unlikely that this was a bacterial
infection and add to that
the patient had a very low procalcitonin
level
the pneumococcal and legionella antigen
in the urine were negative and so the
question is
what would you all do next
well
this patient went to the icu this was
you know midway through the fur second
wave actually for coving for us
uh and the patient was pretty sick any
of us have seen these covered pneumonias
prior to vaccinations
etc know that these patients who go on
ventilators they're pretty sick and they
often stay on ventilators for a while
and that's what happened to this patient
the patient got the typical azithromycin
ceftriaxone the intensivists i mean in
fairness looking at these patients
especially on these people are really
sick
he got nervous
that maybe he was missing something so
he added meripenum and then he added
cefepine
he remained on a mechanical ventilator
and these people who get on mechanical
ventilators may be on ventilators for
months
and he spiked a fever on day
12 of 103 and his blood and
should be tracheal aspirate
agree with the same thing and this is
what the gram sting looked like from his
tracheal asteroid which showed
gram-negative diplicoxide and i'll show
you what that what that represents in a
minute he grew out acinetobacter that
they looked just like nicerious
sometimes on gram stain and this was a
so-called crab
which stands for carbopen ace resistant
acetobacter bomani so because of overuse
of antibiotics have we paid attention to
the initial culture have we paid
attention to the negative pro-calcitonin
level this patient probably shouldn't
have received all the antibiotics he did
and in
light of that we selected out for a very
multi drug resistant organism that
became life threatening in this
particular patient's case so we didn't
we didn't take advantage of all the
information we had available we also
were beginning to realize at that time
that in fact co-bacterial infections
with cova was pretty uncommon
this is just one of several studies that
told us
that in fact less than five percent
there's a beautiful meta-analysis that
just came out which is not part of the
slide deck that showed exactly the same
thing less than five percent of these
patients in multiple studies have
co-bacterial infections and yet over
sixty percent of patients
uh who come in with coping pneumonia end
up getting antibiotics
this particular study also looked at
pro-calcitonin and they found greater
than 0.5 remember we talked about that
greater than 0.5
was the strongest predictor of having a
co-bacterial infection but even at
greater than 0.5
almost a quarter of them after study
didn't have bacterial infection but the
strongest
help
for pro-calcitonin was its negative
predictive value so if it was less than
0.1
the negative predictive value was 98
for bacterial infection so getting back
to the patient in question if we paid
attention or more attention to that
pro-calcitonin level we would have
stopped his antibiotics and we wouldn't
have selected out for this very
resistant organism in fairness to the
team taking care of them this was fairly
early on in our experience with covid uh
we treat these patients very differently
today than we did back in 2020
uh and then procalcitonin in covid we've
already talked about
how it fits it also can be somewhat
prognostic as you can see here
that if you had less than 0.05 in the
beginning the patient was unlikely to
die and as the pro-calcium tunnel level
goes up it's more likely they have a
secondary bacterial infection
and their mortality tends to be higher
so what are some of the lessons learned
uh obviously procalcitonin
if it's less than 0.05 or certainly less
than 0.1
it's consistent with the viral process
and if you have that available in-house
which if you're going to use
pro-calcitonin it's best you have the
platform in-house
that's pretty much consistent with a
viral
process the urinary engine for
pneumococcus and legionella was negative
we grew out normal flora we didn't grow
out staph aureus we didn't grab any gram
negatives
and the overuse of antibiotics as i
mentioned selected for an ndro and now
that we understand this disease better
we know that co-infections with covid
with bacteria are very very low
so let's shift gears now for the rest of
our time together and say okay so we've
looked cap and we've looked at
biomarkers we know there are new
diagnostic studies that are coming down
the pipe
what about
copd and bronchitis and is there a value
of pro-calcitonum because as you know
people who meet the definition of copd
with exacerbation
uh based on the gold score almost all of
them get antibiotics and the question is
is that always necessary
so let's take a look at this
pro-calcitonin guided
of standard therapy for use in lower
respiratory tract infections that again
looked at exacerbation of copd on the
left and acute bronchitis on the right
and you look at the control group and
you can see the antibiotic exposure the
number of patients receiving an
antibiotic therapy was much lower in the
procalcitonin group
versus the control group remember what i
said earlier greater exposure
antibiotics changes our microbiome
it is selects out for resistance side
effects c diff
all can be decreased
if we
shorten or don't expose people
to antibiotics when they don't need it
so if we look at this other study uh
that
that we did here in houston we looked at
139 of our patients
with uh 64 in the pre-intervention group
75 in the post-intervention group all
these people had to be at least 18 so
they're supposedly adults
they had diagnosis of copd with uh with
exacerbation that met the standard
uh and they all had to have a
pro-calcitonin level drawn in the first
24 hours and these were people who were
admitted so
maybe a little bit sicker uh than the
average so but they had to be admitted
they all had copd with exacerbation
with the implementation of
pro-calcitonin guidance that is if they
got a pro-calcitonin level and that
level was less than 0.25
okay
antibiotics were recommended to be
discontinued versus
pre-procalcitonin so in that particular
we had a significant reduction in the
number of antibiotic days of therapy
went from 7.1 days down to 2.4 days we
also wanted to make sure there were no
unintended consequences or harm so we
looked at respiratory related 30-day
readmission rates it didn't differ we
wanted to look at treatment failures
meaning we stopped antibiotics the
patient had an unexpected transfer to
the icu
not statistically different what about
going on invasive ventilation not
statistically significant so there was
no difference in terms of unintended
consequences within the group and we
greatly reduce the number of days on
therapy for antibiotics so this was a
very successful program and now has been
hardwired in our institution as well
so the other thing that i i sort of
alluded to earlier
and that is
the
tremendous value of the negative
predictive value of procalcitonin so you
can see here that uh the the cutoff
again 0.5 or 0.25 and you want to look
at these syndromes fever and neutropenia
sepsis in the ed sepsis syndrome or cap
and i've shown you some of the data for
cap the
negative predictive value is very very
high so if you have a a normal pro
calculate less than 0.1 or less than
0.25
that's highly unlikely
that that patient has a bacterial
infection
now what about
real world experience
if you have an effective protocol in
place and by that i mean
that it's integrated into your
antimicrobial stewardship program i
can't emphasize that enough to be
successful whether it's a molecular test
whether it's a biomarker
you need to make it actionable it needs
to be integrated into your stewardship
program if you do that
you can see significant benefits so if
you look at before and after you look at
days of therapy on the left
and that's how we measured antibiotic
use
significant reduction in terms of deo
therapy you want to look at all cause
readmission
significantly down with procalcitonin
because remember i told you you have
less antibiotic exposure you're less
likely to get secondary infections and
less likely to get c diff
adverse drug events are down
all-cause mortality is down and here's
that c diff that i keep talking about
also significantly down so this is a
real world impact of
pro-calcitonin guided
therapy
in a facility
that has a very active antimicrobial
stewardship
the next question is because if you talk
to the c-suite and you talk to your bean
counters
if i'm going to put this test in place
does it save money now we always talk as
clinicians we want to improve outcomes
and but
bean counters
like to know what the value proposition
is they want to know what the business
case is for implementing pro-calcitonin
algorithm and again i want to emphasize
it's got to be integrated into your
system but if you do
and you want to look at the financial
success and this is just one study
okay you can see first of all costs go
down in a variety of space okay
you look at all of these parameters
whether it's laboratory c diff
antibiotic use you can see there's a
significant reduction across the board
from a pre
uh steward excuse me pro calcitonin to a
post
and you can see reduction right across
the board
and so there's no question that if you
do it correctly and you integrate it
into your
stewardship program you will not only
see better outcomes but as i've always
said good quality
almost always leads to
reduced costs
and i think this certainly plays and you
can see
the tremendous reduction
just per patient
in a very robust program
so just a few final thoughts and then
we'll open it up for questions
uh i want to talk about the
de-escalation space a little bit
because i can understand when data is
being accumulated
you may not have all the data to make
all the final decisions you may
initially decide to start empiric
antibiotics
so let's look at what we can do with a
de-escalation strategy well can we
implement clinical decision support
that's really the you know using
precision medicine you know that's sort
of the holy grail and we're beginning to
be able to look at some of the tools
that can help us get there such as
giving clinicians at the point of order
entry what's the risk of an mdro as an
example and do they need a broad
spectrum antibiotic when a more standard
or narrow spectrum drug is is still as
good
have a very robust antimicrobial team
we're beginning to look more and more
about how we can integrate rapid
diagnostics most people now are looking
at blood cultures but as i mentioned
there's now lower respiratory paddles
that may become on board in a place near
you uh we can certainly de-escalate in
terms of cultures but that's sort of a
late thing and some people are very slow
to de-escalate even when a culture has
been identified we can look at
indications when we actually prescribe
an antibiotic there's great
opportunities for iv to po when you have
a po drug that has good
bioavailability uh there's the
antibiotic timeout which has had some
success where just like in the operating
room in two or three days time out what
are the cultures show how's the patient
going the patient's on drug a do with
the patient need to still continue the
antibiotic at all or
can we use a narrower spectrum drug etc
and then this course duration of therapy
we've learned that most of the common
clinical syndromes we can treat the
patient with fewer dr fewer days which
means they have less exposure to
antibiotics and then how do we integrate
a biomarker like procalcitonin and i've
already said you can do it on the front
end you can also look at duration of
therapy in the back end but if you start
antibiotics and you have a consistently
low procalcitonal level as
as we talked about or that coveted
pneumonia case that i just mentioned
maybe we start antibiotics initially we
get the pro-calcitonin level it's
undetectable
it's an opportunity to de-escalate and
reduce antibiotic exposure
so let's talk about the summary and
benefits
decrease antibiotic exposure decrease
adverse events such as c diff and other
adverse events such as aki
which shows the decreased readmissions
relapse and reinfections it decreases
mortality
decreases icu and length of stay which
the bean counters love decreased length
of state and it reduces all these other
costs
which i went over on a prior slide and
as i mentioned before it has a very high
negative predictive value
and facilitates
de-escalation so those are the benefits
so what are some of the best practices
that i've seen
if you're going to use procalcitonin one
obtain an initial level as close to the
time of starting antibiotics so you have
a baseline
trend that over the next oh 24 to 48
hours
if it is a true bacterial infection you
should begin to see the pro calcium tone
will come down if it starts to go up or
it doesn't come down at all think about
whether or not you've got the right drug
or whether or not you have a source
control issue
initial
you should always initiate antibiotics
patient you think has severe sepsis it's
important to do it in a timely manner
don't delay antibiotics based on the
pro-calcitonin result don't do that
and i mentioned the high negative
predictive value for sepsis initiate
antibiotics for suspected sepsis as i
mentioned timely is important delaying
it is not appropriate
but pro-calcitonin may be ordered sort
of downstream
after antibiotics are started to try to
differentiate bacteria from
non-bacterial these covid patients for
all the world look like severe sepsis
okay
and it may be non-bacterial it may be
other causes of sirs or sepsis so you
still can use that but don't delay
antibiotic if you think the patient's
got severe sepsis and then i already
mentioned
the value of using it for de-escalation
and the kinetic clearance of
procalcitonin being being a good way to
measure
whether or not
you can stop the antibiotic we mentioned
about how it can be used for respiratory
tract infections especially exacerbation
of copd and bronchitis
and then a word of caution
and that is the pro-calcitonin in
general
should not be ordered in patients with
renal insufficiency given the fact that
levels tend to be elevated anyway
and it's cleared by the kidney so that
levels may be elevated and it'll be very
difficult to interpret so i just
discourage people from getting it with
renal insufficiency
so i want to end on on this slide
uh and you know the old antigen
antibiotics were miracle drugs you know
when penicillins were first introduced
into clinical practice in the 1940s
this was a huge breakthrough and then
more types of antibiotics became
available and they didn't seem to be
much of a downside risk
however as most of you know we have
fewer new drugs coming on the market we
have increasing antimicrobial systems
which by the way has been accelerated
by covin in a recent cdc report
but the new paradigm is on the right
it's good when they're used well
and better when they're used
thoughtfully i i hate to see what i call
the desert practice of medicine that i
see so frequently in the emergency
department where they give them
vancomycin and piptazo or they give them
vancomycin placefeme
and then they worry about everything
else later now in the severely septic
patients especially septic shock that's
appropriate
but in many of these patients there is
time to get more information before we
decide on prescribing an antibiotic and
that's what i mean by when you use it
thoughtfully take advantage of all the
clinical information is available and if
you have a for instance a procalcitonin
platform in your facility that may be
one bit of additional information you
use
to decide on whether you start
antibiotics or
when you can stop antibiotics so i think
that's important so with that i'm going
to stop now and i hope we have plenty of
time for questions and i hope we
have some questions but i hope i gave
you sort of a good foundation about how
to integrate all the information you
have whether it's a rapid diagnostic
test whether it's a biomarker uh trying
to use all the species
i'll stop there and see if anyone has
the questions
thank you dr septimus
for your informative presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now just click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for
let's get started our first question is
is pct used differently in cap versus
aecopd
not not really as i as i showed you with
uh with cap there can be some overlap so
people uh
have sometimes problems looking at what
the cut-off should be
but they both can be used at least
philosophically the same way if you have
a very low pro-calcitonin level less
than 0.25 less than 0.1 okay that's when
you have very strong negative predictive
value if you have a fairly high pro
calcium low 4 5 6 10 then that's
certainly more likely to be bacterial
it's in that gray area of 0.25 to 5.5 to
1 excluding renal insufficiency
where there can be some overlap and
that's why you have to use clinical
judgment and other information that you
have in deciding on antibiotics but
great negative predictive value and if
it's obviously higher it's more likely
to be bacterial for a cap but
exacerbations of copd and bronchitis
very strong data to say if it's got the
procalciton is low
you don't have to give antibiotics
all right thank you
next question
can procalcitonin be falsely low in the
presence of bacterial infection
i think we kind of touched on that
during the presentation if you have a
localized infection
um
you may not get an elevated
pro-calcified we have people come in
with urinary tract infections people i
mentioned who had boils or fur uncles
that that were fairly large diabetics
patients who come in with diabetic foot
infections with osteomyelitis
those are conditions where
pro-calcitonin may not go up because
they're localized and not more systemic
so yes you can get false negatives but
if you see someone who's got a boil and
it's got pus and you see someone's got a
diabetic crit infection uh
if the pro calcitonin level is low
don't take that to mean they don't need
antibiotics that's why i'm saying you
always have to look at the patient and
also understand and the reason i gave
you that false negative slide that
certain localized infections
you may not elevate procalcitonin you
should always go based on your clinical
impression right thank you
next question
how should pct be used during flu season
great question uh we haven't seen flu
because of
covet and as i and as i mentioned you
know with covid especially early on in
the code
presentations the procalcitonal level if
it's pure covalent pneumonia tends to be
low by the way just a little caveat
patients who are in the intensive care
unit for a long period of time they they
get more of an inflammatory response
over time that
uh
that kind of activation and so their
pro-calcitonum level by the way
sometimes can go up with
hyperinflammatory states and i mentioned
that about
false positives but the fluid in some
ways is like coving
and that if it's pure flu or by the way
as i mentioned other viral ideologies
rsv
paraflu
metanomavirus rs other viral etiologies
can cause pneumonia in adults
uh and that so procalcitonin can be used
in that clinical syndrome if you think
it's virus chest x-ray looks viral why
counts normal as an example
and you have a low procalcitonal level
whether it's influenza or rsp or other
viruses you can still use that value of
procalcitonin
to try to differentiate whether it's
viral or bacterial especially when we
don't have the test back yet if you have
a multiplex upper respiratory viral
panel you may not have that result in
the first day or so but it can be used
the same way we did it in kobe
i see thank you
next question
is pct elevated in pediatric patients
with otitis media superative om
in general not the data around use of
procalcitonin in pediatrics is a little
bit less clear than it is in adults
and so it's it's not something that's
accurately been pursued in the pediatric
area but again otitis would be
considered a localized infection
thank you
next question
do you see different applications for
pct in covid19 patients upon
presentation
in the ed versus those admitted to the
hospital
a great question i kind of alluded to
that in my previous answer so uh
generally speaking as the patient that i
presented uh earlier
uh most of them will have pure covalent
pneumonia and that's the overwhelming
majority of patients who have this
ground glass bilateral interstitial kind
of appearance
they're going to have a low process
procalcitonin level after they get
admitted to the hospital those ones that
unfortunately end up getting on
ventilator they get this
hyperinflammatory response this sort of
cytokine
storm type of picture
they will begin to elevate procalcitonin
because of that hyperinflammatory
response independent
of having a bacterial infection so if
you catch them early they're generally
going to be low
if they're in that hyperinflammatory
response and we've all seen it those
patients who end up chronically on
ventilators then the pro-calcitonin may
be elevated for other reasons other than
infection and it becomes a little bit
more difficult to interpret to be honest
all right thank you
next question
how is pct used in patients on
hemodialysis
well that's a great question it's i
again i also try to address that i i
don't like to get pro-calcitonin levels
in patients who have renal insufficiency
or hemodialysis now if you hemodialyze
someone let's say you have a
pro-calcitonal level of four and you
hemodialyze you'll get some clearance on
the pro calcitonal level so it may look
like it's coming down
where in fact it's due to hemodialysis
so i tell people
not to get pro calcitonin levels because
they're difficult to interpret
occasionally
someone will get a level
patients otherwise clinically stable
renal function stable even though it's
abnormal
and maybe they have a high procalcitonal
level in some cases if all things being
stable sometimes you can follow that
level even though they have renal
insufficiency and see the level come
down
but in general i try to discourage
people from getting pro-cal levels in
renal insufficiency
i see thank you
and we'll wrap up with that question
thank you dr septimus do you have any
final comments for our audience
well my question is first of all thank
you for spending the hour with me
i hope this was a value added to your
education
uh and again i'm just going to emphasize
the same points whether it's a rapid
diagnostic a multiplex channel whether
it's a biomarker like procalcitonin
always try to integrate that with the
patient that's in front of you to make
the best possible choice and to
interpret the numbers uh that makes
sense in the patient you're seeing so
very very important not
not to use the test in isolation well
that would be my big message that being
at the bedside still matters
but these tests are very helpful
in trying to help us make better
decisions
great well thank you again dr septimus
for your time today and your informative
presentation
we would also like to thank lab roots
and our sponsor thermo fisher scientific
for underwriting today's educational
webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time goodbye
you